I bet you 20 bucks someone's gonna say
let's learn another shrimp on the barbie
Oh
Chantell you what bet butters you never
made this one well uh Loretta's play to
tell you I'm she arbor jest Javed full
of please can I get you to say with me
my iya aye iya
it's me after half a beer so there are
certain parts of Australia but the
Aussie accent is so thick I can't even
understand it the thing that does now is
Australians love to merge words whether
it be on purpose or not I can confirm
that's how a lot of Ozzy's speak in
country towns so anchorman you came
pretty close you did a good job just
course the real hand bill doesn't mean
that other bunch of malarkey is they put
in words that we never used like Malaki
when you hear an Australian accent in a
Hollywood film it does stand out like
dogs balls hey your arrival black it's a
shame that he's saying something pretty
racist yes but at the same time it's not
that shocking if that's his accent I
know that's an Australian actor but that
accent turned way up I'm gonna report
this to me Member of Parliament oh gosh
I got sad that there abort oh yeah I'm
from a small town and our local Member
of Parliament did live close by and
that's how my dad did approach him I
want to take this all the way to the
Prime Minister I hate that this is our
biggest representation of who we are
right mr. Prime Minister if you're
looking for Malcolm Turnbull there's a
pretty good chance that he's just like
floating in a little ring drinking a can
of fosters
the last time we did have a prime
minister go in the water he went missing
I like it I feel like it just takes the
piss but not offensively it's hilarious
it's just a bit of fun if people are
thinking that this is offensive to
Australia every other episode of The
Simpsons is making fun of America even
this episode that a lot of Jewish people
were you from ah no what did do fiddler
on the roof though in high school was
like me and some aboriginals is really
Jewish so whenever Aboriginal people
come up in Hollywood movies it's usually
just as the butt of the joke or anything
like that when I see cheap gags like
that it's kind of like Oh God yet again
you serious and I do wonder whether like
an international audience see
and actually think that when that stupid
I hope not to be an Aussie on camera
doesn't mean you have to be full bogan
yeah [ __ ]
don't worry big you can play this game
because I just go in Barrow underneath
it
smack got lots of swearing yeah accurate
I can accurate he's fun he's laid-back
and I guess at our core that's what most
of us are these are and when we are
around Americans we do kind of
exaggerate our Australian accent and
culture because we want to be that cool
person in their eyes it was like they
had goggle box on in my apartment so
that was spot-on
it's an Aussie trying to get American
onto Australian beer and watch
Australian sport Aussies are all guilty
for that after today I definitely saw
the stereotype that I knew I would see
it's the same stuff over and over again
obviously it would be cool to get like a
little bit more variety diversity yeah
it'd be nice I mean a lot of it was just
taking the piss on us and as Australians
were pretty chill and we just don't give
up all of these portrayed us is kind of
uncultured your bows and that's not true
you can't in australian shows if you see
an American character will portray them
as a big fat loudmouth then how is that
different to vendors making us out as
bogans it's all found it's all banter
and it's funny